martin biron mais celle ci auger paul
journet bonsoir monsieur legault qui
lors d'une mêlée de presse ce matin
avant la période de questions qui a
parlé de relâche évidemment qui a parlé
de varia qui a parlé de barrage on est
beaucoup moins barrage aujourd'hui on
est beaucoup plus bulle familiale
je vous fais entendre monsieur legault
et on va entendre après tout de suite et
madame anglade parce que l'opposition
ait beaucoup à aller sur les variants et
est ce qu on les détecte assez ou pas en
équation
c'est très inquiétant ces niveaux
variables
d'ailleurs ça va jouer dans les
décisions qu'on va prendre des
prochaines semaines concernant les
mesures il ya un risque pour le mois de
mars ce qui va être le plus important
pendant la semaine de relâche
c'est que les bulles familiales soient
respectés si il ya un couvre-feu si les
restaurants sont pas ouverts si la
surveillance pour que les bulles
familiales soient respectés je pense que
c'est bien plus important que net des
barrages
comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui on est
en train de se dire pourquoi on n'est
pas prêt à faire face aux variants la
chasse aux variants la cedh ya dix
semaines qu'on aurait dû la commencé
quand on nous dit que l'ontario depuis
une semaine fait le criblage de 100% des
tests et puis que nous on nous promet
que d'ici une à deux semaines
on va le faire mais là on al'exemple
patins que le québec est en retard
alors martin biron sujet de votre choix
c'est sûr vous allez sur pas de bahreïn
monsieur legault a été assez clair je
pense qu'il veut pas s'encombrer de
barrage mais il voudrait que les gens
il veut tout rassemblement donc on va
surveiller ils sont davantage le sport
c'est si c'est difficile de prendre
cette décision là parce que des
divisions un peu partout notamment dans
les zones oranges où les gens qui font
des affaires veulent recevoir les gens
dans les chalets ou dans les les
installations touristiques mais a quand
même des gens qui aimeraient ne voir
personne et ça se répercute au caucus de
la caq ça se répercute soucis au conseil
des ministres où tout le monde protègent
un peu ses clientèles
monsieur legault va annoncer mardi ce
qui va faire je n'ai jamais été très
friands des barrages monsieur legault y
en a eu pendant le premier confinement
est ce assez vite et lyon ils ont vite
été levée les policiers aussi n'aime pas
soutenir barrage parce que tu es là tout
le temps à demeure puis finalement il ya
des gens qui pensent pour toutes sortes
de raisons alors l'idée c'est beaucoup
plus de se rendre sur les sites vous les
familles pourraient être et de
surveiller pour s'assurer qu'ils
respectent le couvre-feu qu'ils fassent
ce qu'ils font mais de toute façon
monsieur legault ya un autre facteur qui
est important les enfants sont en
relâche
s'ils sont confinés chez eux ils font
quoi ils vont magasiner dans les les
commerces non essentiels qui sont
ouverts et qui fermeront visiblement pas
il reste à la maison il écoute la télé
et me redit ce qu'on veut justement
c'est qu'ils puissent profiter un peu de
la nature et sortir alors ce sera pèse
dans la balance je manquais pas trois
familles dans le même chalet là c'est
cela crée un couplé avec ce nuage de
varia mais je vous signale
je souhaite qu'avec ça mais les corps
n'ont pas monté encore alors s'il y
avait tant de variantes ne pas l'avoir
temps puisque les comme montre elle ne
peut pas c'est pas de parenthèses les
barrières mais michel alesi sur le
l'aspect que vous voulez vous choisi par
des cap verdiens il y en a pas tant que
ça donc c'est un peu pour faire monter
encore mais il ya un danger là c'est
clair quant aux barrages soyons clairs
l'oci plus c'est plus important pour le
bien-être psychologique que ça donne à
certains que de quelques l'efficacité
c'est à peu près comme les frontières ça
c'est pas par l'ocs qui est un véritable
problème c'est justement ce que le
gouvernement ne veux penser qu'à la
faveur de la semaine de relâche on se
retrouve comme il ya eu à noël et au
jour de l'arbre des rassemblements femme
est quand même un petit peu du sud a
demandé au monde de pot au noir à noël
mais et on a vu après ça il ya eu une
augmentation des cas dans les semaines
qui ont suivi
parce qu'il ya eu des rassemble c'est ça
qui veut éviter à tout prix
je m'assure que le barrage entre une
région une autre voilà qui est bien
résumé paul bailly lidl façon de voir
les choses et en actes qui avec la
baisse et sam des cas ce disque ont
peut-être se permettre un petit
relâchement
et puis qui vont peut-être même plus se
justifier elle même lors des égarements
où il ya d'autres façons de voir les
choses qui dit ben le confinement les
efforts qu'on a faits dans les dernières
semaines ça fonctionne donc il faut
continuer pour éviter encore une fois de
jouer au yoyo donc là on prend monsieur
lebon à part peut-être certains petits
ajouts mesures pour la semaine de
relâche
il veut surtout c'est s'assurer que les
mesures en place soit appliquée aux
questions de barrages routiers mois a
priori j'avais vu une contradiction dans
le message gouvernemental je me disais
avec le couvre-feu on dit aux gens qu'on
leur fait pas confiance qu'on les
surveille
alors qu'avec les barrages ben on leur
dit qu'on leur fait confiance mais
finalement en grattant un peu j'ai
réalisé que ni les policiers ne suggère
les barrages ni même les maires de
région qui disent que puisse pas
vraiment efficace une mesure symbolique
un mot sur le couvre-feu
et ce qui lance aussi comme message très
clair c'est qui est là au moins jusqu'au
début du printemps martin oui puis c'est
peut-être ça la mesure supplémentaire
peut-être qui va resserrer le couvre-feu
en zone orange pendant la période de
relâche pour s'assurer que tout le monde
est là mais je faisais des eaux troubles
ces visites pas trop mais oui ça va
aller aux autres qu au moins jusqu'à
minimes arcis très certainement ok
parlant de bulle familiale
je le gros début de son point de presse
il devrait parler d'une chose de l'attak
de la veille du chef du parti québécois
y était c'est le premier sujets qu'il a
abordés ce matin on en écoute ça et
monsieur bérubé qui a dû aller au bâton
pour défendre son chef
alors on est quoi quand il dit que les
enfin d'être fauché - instruments son
jeu les enfants ben et chez moins ce que
je voudrais dire à monsieur st pierre
plamondon au chef du pq sexta ces deux
hommes semblent la politique qu'on
devrait laisser les enfants en dehors de
tout
prune journée avec sa famille
aujourd'hui le deux jeunes enfants
voilà côté et s'est expliqué le sujet
c'est que dans le journal de québec de
décembre 2019 dans les voeux de noël
le 1er mai il se dit qu'il accueillait
chez lui ses enfants qui n'habitent pas
avec lui donc on n'était pas au courant
que sa venue dans dernières années le
déménagement c'est tout
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut rappeler
peut-être les gens avec nous il sait que
paul st pierre plamondon avait dit à la
fin d'une conférence de presse martin
je comprends pas pourquoi monsieur
legault on demande aux québécois d'un
tir et à monsieur lebon à ses enfants
prennent des photos et cetera est-ce que
l'incident est clos
bah écoutez on pensait hier qu'il était
clos si c'est intéressant parce qu'on en
a parlé je l'avais dit il ya un code non
écrit à québec on ne touche pas ni aux
enfants ni aux conjoints conjointe des
politiciens à moins d'être béton béton
solide et monsieur st pierre plamondon
il est tombé dans le piège
il pensait que le dossier était clos il
s'est excusé sur en fait il est retiré
ses propos sur twitter il a tenté de
rejoindre monsieur legault hier mais
monsieur legault n'a pas pris son appel
ah bon il l'a rappelé ce matin pour
s'expliquer avec lui
monsieur legault n'a pas pris son effet
c'est nouveau pour moi
ce qui est intéressant dans le message
de monsieur legault qui a ouvert son
point de presse et qu' ils envoient le
message précis ou parti québécois qu'il
ne leur fera pas de cadeau et je peux
vous dire que ça a ébranlé les péquistes
oui parce que la force d'un premier
ministre en début de conférence de
presse michel c ils ont ils pas allés il
a répondu non seulement du tac au tac
mais il ya répondu peut-être plus fort
que même la tacle oui et c'est ce qui
est dangereux dans ce que je sais le
goût à fait monsieur s'était
imprudemment dos s'était excusé il y
avait retiré son tweet les retouches et
ça alors un moment de vrai monsieur
leveaux a toute la patinoire à lui à
chaque fois qu'il parle toutes les
langues et toutes les télés son rôle en
été et en direct le temps c'est un
avantage qu'il faut justement pas perdre
par des crises attaques partisanes comme
ça parce qu'à un moment donné on va être
obligés d'y écouter leur donne pas le
temps d'antenne ici pour faire de la
propagande prisé par la donne on va
entendre parler le 1er mai s'il veut
régler ses comptes politique
il va perdre les avantages qui n'a et
c'est un gros avantage est de style as
well
je pense qu'on est au-delà de la
stratégie avait quelque chose
personnelle là dedans
monsieur legault c'est quelqu'un qui
peut être impulsif puis le propre
histoire
personnel même serveur un tentative de
monsieur plamondon d'une offre l'autre
s'excuser on savait qu'il y avait besoin
de régler ses comptes en public puis je
note que c'est toute l'opposition qui
frustré en ce moment québec vous avez
les libéraux uni solidaire qui essaient
de critiquer rationnellement
gouvernement par exemple de dire il faut
une enquête publique puis au lieu qu'on
parle de ça ben pour une deuxième
journée c'est les attaques personnelles
non fondées de monsieur melon d'eau qui
font qu'ils font la manchette puissance
à sa nuit d'abord au pq et ensuite au
reste de l'opposition
oui bon alors justement parlant d'autres
sujets qu'il faut surveiller le manoir
liverpool j'accueille avec nos panel
notre collègue de québec alexandre duval
bonsoir alexandre bonsoir patrice vous
avez publié un texte qui ça va de mal en
pis pour le manoir livres pour d'abord
il ya il rapportera plus aux gens assez
dur sur la maltraitance des mauvais
soins personnes âgées dans sa danse est
rpa de lévis pourquoi le si ce n'est pas
intervenue mais pourquoi monsieur paris
qui était patron du système pas
intervenus ils ne le savaient pas
monsieur paris qui est responsable la
vaccination actuellement et là vous vous
nous dites que à plus ils ont eu de
l'argent de manière vous est il légal
entre des contrats illégaux d'esprit
mois écoutez c'est vraiment une tuile de
plus je dirais non seulement sur le
manoir liverpool mais aussi sur le site
de chaudière appalaches parce que
monsieur paris dont vous avez parlé
c'est le directeur de la campagne de
vaccination contre la coved 19 au québec
actuellement
et lorsqu'on a appris aujourd'hui en
milieu d'après midi
honnêtement je ne savais pas que
l'autorité des marchés publics
travailler là dessus et je pense pas que
quiconque le savez ce qu'on a appris
c'est qu'en 2016 et 2017
le manoir liverpool obtenue de manière
non conforme à la loi de manière
illégale
deux contrats qui étaient octroyés par
le sis de chaudière appalaches ces deux
contrôleurs totalisent ensemble 8
millions huit cent mille dollars alors
c'est beaucoup de sous à
quoi ça sert 20 c contre la patrie sba
c'est simple c'est le réseau de la santé
qui achètent des places ou encore
liverpool pour aller y placer des des
patients du réseau public donc des gens
qui allaient là pour une convalescence
ou des gens qui allaient là à long terme
parce qu'ils avaient besoin de soins
hélas quand on dit que ces contrôles ont
été obtenues de manière illégale c'est
parce que le mal
l'autorité des marchés publics déterminé
que le manoir liverpool n'avait pas
l'autorisation d'obtenir un contrat de
plus d'un million de dollars avec un
organisme public au québec il faut
passer à travers un processus avec
l'autorité des marchés publics qui a des
contacts avec l'upac pour s'assurer que
l'entreprise est intègre le manoir
liverpool n'a jamais passé par là et le
sis de chaudière appalaches n'ont jamais
vérifié si le manoir liverpool était
passé par ce processus là avant de dire
ok go on vous donne les contres à
l'instant beta pour lier pour les deux
parties c'est bien résumé alexandre
duval ou un bravo parce que en fait
merci beaucoup je tourne le temps paul
vous avez écrit la tuyère sur monsieur
parent et ne sachant pas dans cette
nouvelle histoire
mais toute la question d'imputabilité là
on apprend à plus que les contrats pour
recevoir des résidents ont été faits
peut-être un peu vite en plus ils
étaient maltraités est ce que est ce que
on peut quand même conclure que monsieur
paris devait le savoir aurait dû savoir
le savez ou pas où j'en est là écoutez
lui prétend qu'il ne le savait pas mais
il faut dire qu'il est donc qui pourra
responsable mais pas coupable mais la
culpabilité est une chose la
responsabilité c'en est une autre
même si vous n'êtes pas directement
coupable d'une mauvaise décision vous
devez en être responsable quand même
donc ça c'est quand même une chose qu'il
faut dire même si monsieur paré dit
qu'il ne le savait pas même si on
accepte sa version ça veut dire qu'il ya
un gros problème que le pdg n'était pas
au courant et qu'il faut absolument
comprendre pourquoi pdg n'était pas au
courant et corriger cette lacune
une partie de la réponse sans doute ici
c'est ça la vérité qu'il ne le savait
pas c'est que les six sont rendus de
gros monstres mais quand même ça nous
ramène jeter revue nature la promesse de
christian dubé de rétablir
l'imputabilité des réseaux les pdg sont
nommés par le ministre maintenant depuis
la réforme bar est donc le lien direct
avec monsieur libe alors c'est une bonne
distraction vous faites paul martin et
michel c'est le premier ministre
aujourd'hui a dit moi je suis pour
l'imputabilité jeu l'était pour dans
l'opposition je suis maintenant show
gouvernement même s'ils ne le savaient
pas martin ça pose la question est ce
que le patron du cices doit quand même
être responsable de la qualité de vie
dans les maisons dont on est on a la
responsabilité quoi monsieur legault a
dit aussi dans son point de presse
j'aime pas ça moi pas savoir qui est
responsable d'une situation aussi grave
que ce qui s'est passé au manoir
liverpool mais aujourd'hui c'est une
très mauvaise journée je sais pas
combien clou ça prend pour ses lire un
cercueil mais aujourd'hui il y en a deux
qui sont tombés qui ont été plantés dans
ce circuit est là est-ce que alexandre
viennent nous raconter avec le rapport
de l'autorité des marchés publics
mais ce matin alexandre avait publié un
autre texte oui il nous faisait pas que
plus de 11 de plus de 10 % des plaintes
concernant le manoir liverpool était
concerné le manoir liverpool au
commissaire aux plaintes et à la qualité
des services donc pour la région
avant lui seuls 10% des plaines de aider
à 300 maisons delà du coin alors il y
avait des doutes sur le problème de
maltraitance dans cet état dans cet
établissement la bon comment se fait-il
que monsieur paris ne le savais pas ça
commence à faire beaucoup le s'ajoute au
dossier de monsieur paris ok je vais
vous donner à parler alexandre là dessus
parce que j'ai été quelque chose à midi
qui m'a fait un ticket alors restez là
bougeait pas michel rapidement ça
s'accumule en effet c'est embêtant
maintenant monsieur on ne sais pas
peut-être ils ne savaient pas ma corde
face qui se poser des questions au fils
de m oui y'a pas de preuves de magique
de malversations ne te retourne pas du
tout début du système d'autorité des
marchés publics
et peut-être que les gens pensaient de
bonne foi qui avaient le droit de faire
ce contrôleur
cela dit cette hausse et c'est la job de
monsieur paris comme pdg du sus de
chaudière appalaches de vérifier ces
choses là
alors les [ __ ] habilité c'est pas juste
de s'assurer qu'ils aient pas de bandits
dans la maison c'est de s'assurer qu'ils
processus sont suivis et là n'ont pas
été d'accord
alexandre en conclusion j'avais 10 me
dis il faut faire attention parce que
les plaintes sur le manoir livre paul
n'était pas nécessairement de nature à
remonter jusqu'aux grands patrons
j'avais dit ça je crois n'est ce pas
c'est ce qui nous a été expliqué par le
commissaire adjoint aux plaintes en fait
comme dans les plaintes il n'y avait pas
d'élément de maltraitance on ne disait
pas le mot maltraitance du signalement
pour la maltraitance ont dit on n'avait
pas besoin d'alerté la haute direction
parce qu'on était capable de régler ça
au cas par cas avec des mesures
correctives et semble-t-il que les
usagers qui ont porté plainte étaient
satisfaits des mesures correctives qui
ont été adoptés mais si vous permettez
pas triste je fais juste par sentiment
sur ce que michel audy parce que c'est
très intéressant quand on dit que les
contrats rapidement les contrats ont été
conclus de manière illégale
il rien de criminel là dedans mais c'est
pas conforme à la loi et l'a d'ailleurs
le cabinet du ministre christian dubé
aurait agi en disant que c'est un autre
exemple de cafouillage la part du manoir
liverpool
or mais aussi que le sis de chaudière
appalaches devait vérifier et là il a
demandé à tous les pdg de son réseau de
s'assurer que tous les contres en
ressources intermédiaires
sont conformes à la loi alors c'est pas
rien ce qui vient de se passer cet après
midi non non non non c'est pas rien
certains d'ailleurs se jettent leurs
mais on va continuer votre bon travail
alexandre duval à québec
nous on va en reparler puis la question
de monsieur paris va se reposer
on imagine très très bientôt merci
beaucoup à vous quatre c'est tout un
conte à pourvoir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit